hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we are talking about
imposter syndrome now imposter syndrome
to me
would be defined as feeling like you
don't belong where you are
you are imposter sometimes i can feel
like oh like
you got the job that is so exciting and
then the next three seconds you think oh
my gosh
what am i going to do when they find out
i'm not skilled enough or i'm not good
enough feeling like you
fooled you know them the quan quote them
your family your friends
your company all of that feeling like
you do not
belong but let me tell you here
yeah you do yeah you do and this is
how to really really tackle imposter
syndrome so that
you have to just deal with it less and
less and less
until you no longer feel this way very
first thing when you
feel yourself spiraling down that
imposter syndrome feeling
is to understand what has happened to
make you start feeling this way
so there are many different things that
might happen and there are many ways to
go about this so let's start
with another person externally someone
says something to
you to start feeling this way first of
all remember that what a person says
about you is more of a reflection
on them than it is on you people can't
do things
or couldn't have imagined doing
something and so they tried to put
you down for accomplishing the very
thing that they couldn't
the negative things they say to you are
a reflection of
their own insecurities to them it
doesn't matter who they say it to
if you weren't sitting at that desk
sitting in that chair on the zoo meeting
they would have found somebody else to
spill this nonsense too
so it is not on you not not a reflection
on you
it is completely on them and so you need
to remember that and squash that
real quick if it's not another person it
could be yourself i know this is
something that i've been battling with
very recently me feeling insecure
feeling that i am not good enough to be
in this field i'm not
good enough to be in this company
because the people around me the people
i'm working with the people on this zoo
meeting
look nothing like me and that is
something that is
seriously seriously a real thing because
when you
see all these people flourishing and
getting through their projects with no
problem and
no bugs or anything and then you are
having troubles or in this case for me
many people know that i've been going
through training for my new job
i work as a commerce cloud developer and
i just started last month and i've been
going through training
and so that's been a lot of
something i've need to tackle for myself
where i look at the people around me
and they don't look like me and so i'm
going to
getting into problems and i say to
myself oh i'm not good enough i don't
belong here
x y and z because i see no one else who
looks like me
that people tend to not understand
how important having people that look
like you is
because when i mess up it becomes a
thing of
nigh is the problem and you know nai is
not smart enough in my mind
that that's what ends up happening but
when john messes up it's oh the
instructions weren't clear
or oh the project is just difficult give
them some time
and and i'm not saying the company does
this but just
me looking around like no one says oh
john is stupid
oh chad doesn't belong here no they
don't say that so
i need to stop doing that to myself and
allow
myself the same patience and courtesy
i'm giving to everybody else
saying nay the code base you're working
with is difficult
the instructions are vague you will get
through it you got this
it's fine you'll tackle it as you will
and
really separating it from i'm not good
enough to man these instructions are not
good enough
so really work on separating that think
about what the flip side is
if you are in coding bootcamp if you are
self-teaching
in computer science in your classes or
have just started a new job like me
and you are running into tech problems
you are running
into these glitches constantly stop
making it about you that sounds so harsh
but stop
making it about you it's not about you
no no no
but no do you see what i mean stop
thinking about you make it about what
you're working on
this thing is difficult this thing is
hard this thing
is you know not well updated
and let me work with what i've got it's
going to be harder because it's
structured this way
but let me work with what i got and
acknowledge that the things you're
working on
are hard and the fact that you are
struggling
means that you are about to learn so so
much and that's exactly the third reason
that you may be
going through this the first was another
person saying something second was you
yourself observing your you know
surroundings and putting that insecurity
on yourself
and third is your work
your the technology you're working with
is it that you can't fix a bug
is that what created this feeling that
there's a bug
that is just flashing at you for the
last six hours and you can't fix it
okay get up get up close your computer
and take a break when you take a break
when people say take a break when you're
having troubles with bugs and things
like that
it's not because they're saying oh just
breathe
just chill and you'll get to it
and it'll be fine no that's not why
they're saying that
they are saying it because when you take
a break when you stand up get blood flow
going
move get something to eat watch a show
30 minutes watch some friends watch some
fresh prince of bel air
sit down then come back to your computer
20 minutes 30 minutes an hour after
you are now forced to remind yourself
of where you were you are now forced to
open up your files again you have to
look through
what instructions you're going through
or what tutorial you're going through
and what line of code you are on
and remind yourself what even the point
of that code is
it's in that reminding yourself and
getting reacquainted in yourself
that the magic happens because now that
you've been
forced to take a couple steps back you
now will find the bug you now will
understand what the problem is
either one because you and previously
had lost sight of the bigger picture the
why behind your code
you now came back and we're like oh why
am i working that's what am i working on
and then it clicked you're trying to do
x y and z
and so you know exactly how to make it
work that
or number two it's with the taking a few
steps back
that the bug lied in it wasn't
in the thing that you currently were
looking at it was in the four
steps before that you had done
previous hours ago that created this bug
now
and you didn't know it until now because
it just wasn't relevant
and so now that you had taken a break
and had to start from four steps back
all over again to remind yourself of
where you were you saw that bug
and now you're like oh
there it is that is why it's important
to take a break i
if someone had just said this i would
have started taking breaks a long time
ago then when it works you're no longer
an imposter you know
you made it work you're so happy so
excited and you're now feeling like the
bad mother shut your mouth that you
really are the fourth reason you might
be you know feeling
that impostor syndrome is because you
can't
find work you've done the teaching the
instruction the training
and you can't find work now if that's
the case
yes i see how that can be extremely
extremely
disappointing and i will allow you the
three minutes to cry about it
but after those three minutes you
please please please see all the
different ways you are present on a
professional level your resume your
linkedin your github
all of that and see what things you can
revamp and there's always something you
can revamp
revamp your resume to do x y and z
revamp your linkedin make sure you're
posting a lot more make sure you're
networking make sure you're playing that
game it's a lot better to feel like
you're doing something
than it is to just i don't know
i've i've always felt better doing
things i've always also felt more
motivated and excited about like life
then i have just accepting
defeat um i hope that makes sense again
stop turning things inwards and saying
i'm not good enough and really
reflected on everything else
in terms of okay i'm in a rough economy
right now let me be patient let me
play that networking game let me make
sure i am being present
and people know i'm looking so that i
can have my
best odds of getting the position i want
rather than being
saying oh i'm stupid i'm not good enough
i hate that word even saying it i think
you guys saw i hesitated
i hate that word i hate that but anyway
i do not ever call yourselves stupid or
dumb like it makes me so emotional even
saying it
don't ever call yourself that because if
you
call yourself that you your body your
mind your actions will start believing
it start reflecting it
and that is no way to be not only in
work but in life seriously there are so
many people in this world whose
main purpose in life seems to be to just
drag you
down and so you need to be the one
person who's on your corner
if there is nobody else around and just
be like no you can say whatever you want
with your
computer science degree with your you
know google
internship with your xyz say whatever
you want i'm gonna be over here
working on myself working on these
projects and i'll see you at the top
if you even make it there and i really
wanted to post this video today because
it was very relevant for today
i had been working i had been you know
just
minding my own business eating my
do you guys know that video like eating
my mcdonald's or something
and um i go on instagram
and i see this thread of comments
from a person who was very much
his goal for that day i think was to
find
people he can put down or try to put
down
he had seen my account and everything
and just started saying these belittling
comments saying
things like oh i gave my grandmother a
macbook and she turned it on i guess now
she's
a software engineer too or things like
that
i think he's deleted that comment
but there's more if you can like i'm not
gonna say which post it is but
you'll be able to find it just fine but
if you look for it
but um yeah it was this that made me
for a second just like feel like that
like like an imposter
like am i really good enough x y and z
and i very quickly had to remind myself
of who i am my credentials pull up my
own little resume
and remind myself that i taught myself
to code
and was able to secure a job at a
fortune 20 company
and am now right now working as a
commerce cloud developer
and am contributing everywhere i can and
learning everywhere i can and just
continuing
that process of bettering myself
professionally
in my learning and just i keep looking
over here because that's where my
computer is
so i think i'm also talking to my i
don't know but
um i had to experience that for myself
doing those steps
of remembering who i am and
acknowledging why i'm feeling like this
x y and z and so there will be so many
people y'all especially if you're coming
at this
from a non-traditional route or if
you're a person of color
or a woman in this field there will be
people who
try to put you down for it say you don't
belong say you
took the easy route meanwhile they don't
realize that you spent
60 hours a week up till 3am crying
trying to figure out why certain
processes won't work making sure you're
sending your resume to everybody and
their mama just
working so hard to make sure you make
this life for yourself and some people
just refuse to see those things and
instead when
seeing you they see all the things that
they couldn't
do and they decide to put you down for
that and so i really wanted to make this
video for y'all but also for myself and
i'm really excited for the next few
weeks getting to interact with you more
both on social media and here
i plan to make more tutorial videos
don't worry i know y'all on it
don't worry i've been working a lot i
work about 70 hours a week because
two of my contracts overlap each other
but in two weeks that will be done and
so i'll be
giving you so much more of that so
please be patient with me
and i'm looking forward to creating some
day in the life videos
for you all getting to talk about really
what i do on a day-to-day
and really just yeah try to give you all
some
insight into what you may expect in this
type of
role so i really hope you enjoyed this i
hope
you remember some of these things i hope
i remember some of these things
but youtube tells me that about 70 of
you
are enjoying my content but don't
subscribe so please click that subscribe
button i love seeing this community grow
and i'll see y'all later bye y'all